[Music]  Blake Lively and Ryan Reynolds are  having fun going at it over cheating  Blake posted on Instagram that Anna  Kendrick is quote the hotter female  version of my husband so what it really  count as cheating Anna and Blake co-star  in the upcoming film a simple favor  Brian answered back the most ambitious  crossover event in history I'll miss you  both tell my story  I love the troll with you and your hubby  on the internet too it's my favorite  kind of follow back if you have fun  we're best friends and Chrissy Teigen  'he's been trolling John Legend with  this post of their daughter holding  Arthur the aardvark with the caption  Luna and daddy  the couple was kidded for a while that  John shares a resemblance with the  beloved cartoon character in an ad for  Google he even dressed up as his  look-alike  [Laughter]  you